i can't believe this guys i just made a
big mistake i told christian that i was
rolling and i wasn't rolling and now i
am unforgivable now
here we go
[Music]
welcome back to the quarter digital
podcast everybody episode 140 man
there's been more people watching than
normally recently and i gotta say
welcome to anybody who's new or if
you've already been subscribed but you
just uh want to hear more about the
software and tech talk uh then you know
well i'm just glad that people are
tuning in so um
welcome everybody hope you're having a
great day uh who do we have today we've
got sam gorski the one and only in the
flesh
and the flesh yeah here i am on my phone
doing
god's work
doing god's work we got matt karen's hi
everyone hi i'm here too i haven't been
on a podcast in a while and it's because
i've been in the trenches on something
very special yep
trenches and today's a very special day
actually i'm kind of riding a little bit
of a high we'll talk about that later um
we'll talk about his heart yeah yeah
there's a very specific type of drugs
hello
hello hello jordan allen
it's an honor
aka beans see this is this is a fallacy
all right because beans my name is not
beans jordan coleman's name is beans
okay i want it fair and square all right
i want it fair and square and i feel
like contractually you guys are
obligated to refer to her as beans fair
and square
in a game of
smash that she was obviously
undermatched against you on i don't know
if that's fair and square
kind of sticks but listen
listen here we are just like them sticky
beanies yeah
um so sam has a prompt matt has a high
that he was just on that he needs to get
off his chest so yeah
it also has to do with the prompt
honestly i want to see what this is
right
i think i'm going to get a second hive i
don't know how this happened but somehow
someone said that scottish people are
thieves
at some point
revealed to us his scottish heritage
which is obvious because your last name
yeah means rocks rocks
and your pockets are full of jewels yeah
so
i'm asking mid-journey to do a oil
painting of a scottish rock thief
which is technically one of your uh
ancestors oh it looks just like me
they are stealing rocks i don't know
which one you this one's pretty good
the quality is so impressive the
lighting looks gorgeous how do we show
the people this uh can we talk i i also
have some scottish heritage my last name
is also it's scotch irish yes um
which uh i don't know
there's a couple things we could discuss
here okay there's there's the whole
karen's thing yeah like what is it what
is a cairn yeah it's it's uh well it's
not just rocks they're special yeah
they are special they're minerals
um no they're rocks but they uh the
scottish folk uh they they used to bury
their dead because of the the land the
fact that it was so it was hard to
really get your dead buried six feet
under properly so to protect your dead
um and your loved ones that have been to
cc they bury them as far as down as they
can go and then they pile rocks on top
to protect them um and that just kind of
has become the cultural thing over there
he must have been a highlander then a
highlander indeed yeah and then if a
middle-aged woman ever complains about
you digging
that is also a cairn yes but a different
kind of a different kind of candy
you're digging too close to my property
that's a good one
uh they also are used to mark um like
turns and trails and things like that
and in roads
yes as far as i understand it
um yeah and then we can talk about scott
and lot the whole phrase scot-free
um but uh a quick tat on scotch-irish
people many people don't know
they were the first irish people to uh
you know sort of come to america and
when they arrived in the 1700s or so
they were known as the irish because
they came from northern ireland but then
when the uh
irish catholics came they felt the need
to differentiate from such uh
you know
rabble and uh they came up with the
phrase scotch irish which is a
particularly american
reference to um people that lived in
northern ireland were loyal to the crown
and then came to america interesting
yeah mm-hmm
wow and uh more scottish facts uh
scot-free uh stop um
[Laughter]
no i'm just gonna keep going no no have
you guys seen on cinema at the cinema
yeah he's stopping he reminds me i'm
kind of getting great vibes right now
it's all about like taking one
one thing someone says
and then and like then just going as
deep as possible
until it no longer becomes relevant you
know but it's like you come to the
corridor cast everything no it's right
no i i freaking love it one more fact
scot-free so you may have heard this
phrase he got away scot-free okay so
that actually refers to the to scott and
lot yes which um was it was the type of
tax i believe it was a certain type of
tax scott and lot that was supposed to
be paid on certain items and when you
got away scot-free you didn't you didn't
know any tax that's what it means i used
to think it was because everything was
free for a scotsman or
[Laughter]
everything's free if your kilt's big
enough yep yeah and that's another
misconception about irish people
okay a lot of people walk over
slowly
yeah
[Laughter]
oh man
wow
wow good facts
anyway
how did we start on this well so there's
this new thing that you all have been
toying around with we talked about it
last time mid journey oh okay yeah
johnny has talked about but i haven't
messed with it until just moments ago
but i've been wanting to but like we we
followed up on some of our
ideas from last time um we did the
ironman titanic
mashup
that you know it's like in the future
you you want to watch something
and you just tell your computer
a prompt sentence and they'll generate
an entire film oh yeah of you know oh
man yeah yeah so uh this guy on the mid
journey discord uh i think he's friends
with ren basically he just ran that
prompt
to just see what happens and it looks
like terrible fan art but but it's like
really great at the same time
because it's it shows you it's like oh
yeah there you go that's that's our fan
film of
iron man titanic was it actually video
or was it no no it was just images
he just did like the demo images of it
to like i love the heart one
it's like jack and rose in iron man
costumes kissing on the deck of the
titanic oh my god
yeah they really they really captured
the love story element of the titanic
and put it right in iron man's little
little glowy bit dude that is a that is
an interesting precipice upon which we
stand though is like we are we're like
how close to being able to prompt an ai
to give you a movie
as soon as there's the bandwidth and
storage capacity for that i mean that's
going to happen i know i know that's
like the all the environmentalists will
be like
you guys
you guys you gotta recycle
the recycling too much
space okay not processing power
yeah it'll be like blockchain all over
again just with uh people generating
their own movies
yeah well matt i'll send you these two
scottish rock thiefs please
please do it it's going to be my new
profile
i'm going to i don't know which one do
you so which one do you like more do you
like this one where it's a man counting
stones on this in this it looks like he
has
four hands he might have four hands oh
for
the maximum stealing
is the other one oh i like this one a
lot all right well yeah i'll make this
one
on your tinder yeah
i will provide for you all right we'll
process the one and then i have plenty
of stones
if anyone else wants like a classy
stereotype of themselves
let me know yeah it only generates yeah
actually sam can you can you give me
something
can you give me uh can you give me a
classy rendering
okay only if it's like slightly um
uh
self-deprecating
okay yeah how about um
how about a uh well you already did
robin scotsman
yes yes
um
how about a uh a murderous scotsman
how about that a murderous murderer
i'm just going off the cuff here i
apologize
uh how about hey how about he wants to
be a murderous scotsman there you go
yeah
[Laughter]
i mean i'm not explaining you but i'm
just saying to take this character and
really give it some depth
you know i like that yeah let's go with
this all right well
we'll circle back in a few minutes
okay thanks appreciate that a murder
ambitious scotsman yes
what other weird ai tools do you have
sam
at my disposal uh yeah not that many
everything is publicly
released at this point we've made videos
about every ai thing we have in house at
this point
yes we have um
one other thing uh that we haven't
gotten to yet
is um matt karen's high on life story
yes yes yes this is what i'm dying to
know it's a little bit of an
exaggeration but you know you gotta you
gotta hit him with the thumbnail first
it's like we submitted to our show to
netflix our first episode and they just
got back to us today
um and they they're pretty amped on it
yeah which i don't know how they
couldn't be uh
well but so yeah but at the same time
you never really know especially when
doing client work what the result is
going to be what their reaction is going
to be you can do as much pre-production
with them and set up what it's going to
be what the show is going to be how it's
going to look
on but none of that really matters until
you actually deliver it and you know you
never really know is it are they going
to like it are they going to hate it how
many what what wall of notes are you
going to get um but uh can i read it can
i just read the
the little uh
yeah read read maybe just one just you
think you keep sentences yeah
yeah just the first line so they got
back to us and right away it was what
the hell this
is the worst thing i've ever seen
scrap it all and reshoot everything
um no they said uh this cobra kai edit
is incredible
very compelling
we're so happy with how it turned out
and that was the first yeah
sentence and that as soon as i read it i
was like yes yes we did it that is yes
it was such a relief to get that crazy
yeah yeah i mean because i mean not that
like i don't need i don't want to go too
in-depth on this statement but it's like
netflix a corporate client yeah right
but at the same time they're also not
because
they're literally making you know films
and shows and stuff too so sure so it's
that weird middle ground of like
are you expecting the hammer mm-hmm or
are you expecting some people to be like
dope cool video and it could have gone
either way but you know yeah their team
over there that we've been working with
is really cool um they've been really
like they they get it they get like how
things get made and it's i think yeah
sam you're probably right like it's
they're not a
you're not making like a product for
some other company that doesn't ever
deal in video and video production
exactly video product so they
they're a lot more in tune with how this
stuff works i think that helps honestly
make better stuff overall exactly
these types of projects are usually with
non-filmmaking entities so to speak you
know they're like maybe creative in some
other space but yeah it's it's it's it's
not that realm but yeah that's great
that's dope well congratulations yeah to
all of us really all the fear of
rejection yeah you know it's like it's
like oh yeah it's behind us we at least
got that first stage of it past us yeah
you know and we're
we got invited on a second date yeah
yeah but you've set the bar high now so
that's the thing that's true but moving
into the date too we got a lot of good
episodes so ahead of us like i think uh
looks good on you i think they'll like
for people who don't know though i'm
sure there's a lot of professionals out
there who understand what it's like to
deliver a product into the void
of what is the client
um so to speak but
it is like you're delivering it you you
spend all this time you try to make like
the best thing you can and then
you submit it into this black void
and
you don't know what's gonna happen yeah
and certainly like the the clients i've
had over the many years of doing this
it's been the other way around where
it's like you know you you work so hard
to try to help them understand your own
vision and you sell them on the vision
and then you deliver the vision and
they're like this is not it at all i
want something completely different
you know it's like that's like the worst
feeling ever when it's it makes you feel
like you're bad at your job you know at
first i have a story about that when we
were uh we shot this uh bit with um
black rifle coffee like two years ago uh
that was called star-spangled steel
which is just basically
you helped me with this yeah i did
that's why i'm laughing
yeah and and uh
it is basically this bit where matt and
evan like play the star-singled banner
with keys uh like um targets that would
when you would hit them they would ping
in a different key so they went through
and they played the the song using um
these nine millimeters that they had and
uh it was like this really cool thing it
was fun we had the whole vision and like
matt you helped me deliver on it and
then i delivered it and
uh matt calls me up and he's like hey um
this i don't know how we got to this
um
but this is not
what we
had talked about
and and i was just like silent for a
second
and i just go
okay well why don't you tell me what we
talked about
yeah
and and then he just burst out laughing
and they were just messing with me
and they were like no this is amazing
this is amazing this is so cool it's we
love it and oh man but it was that
moment where i was like oh man i really
hope they like this spent a whole bunch
of time and heart on it and yeah
yeah
yeah that's that's kind of the scary
thing is that you need to take it to a
certain point creatively for them to
understand it and get it
but that extra effort is often where you
spend so much time risking it you know
there's no in between you kind of need
to do that so you did the whole entire
cut yeah pretty much right yeah yeah
and that's the first viewing yeah so
there's a lot of pressure
yeah
[Laughter]
how can we get this how can we get this
on that is the people that are watching
the video
you can see the blurry version
maybe you can put this in the edit oh
yeah you could maybe yeah
it's like some some cross-eyed
insane person with like looks like they
had just eaten show the scots
bloody heart
although like if you just want to link
it yeah or whatever maybe i take back
what i said about what what i wanted to
see i i take it back i'm i'm trying to
think how it was how it was making sense
of the idea of wanting to murder so he
just like gives himself a bloody nose
it's like a step in the right direction
or it was more like an attempted murder
kind of thing
like i tried to murder someone but i'm
such a wuss that it didn't work you
couldn't find i was all frustrated they
punched they punched me in the mouth
and i said sorry
oh my god
and then on my way out i got hit in the
head with an anvil
[Music]
my god
that's what it looks like do you have
any good like horror stories from
clients
i can be vague enough
[Music]
jordan you worked in the client world
for some time why don't you go first
yeah i i learned a very hard lesson at
an early age and uh this is when we were
me and my uh directing partner luke were
doing a lot of commercial work
and we had bid out on this it was like a
contest site called tongle and you
basically uh you basically pitch for the
client tongle or the intermediary and
then you go ahead and make the content
and then it's like a contest format well
they'll kind of rank you but they'll
give you money up front to actually make
the stuff so we did our whole pitch
video and we were really selling them on
you know the series of six shaving
videos and saying you know
you know men just want to hear it direct
you know how to shave yourself and your
nether regions and how to shave your
head like real heart-to-heart man-to-man
stuff so we pitched like this sincere
thing and then when it came to writing i
just wasn't capable of writing anything
sincere about that and so we just made
it a comedy
six comedic videos
and uh yeah we we spent so much time on
it shooting locations editorial visual
effects all this stuff
and submitted it and i'll be honest in
the process of making it i completely
forgot the creative we promised
i was in a different place entirely this
was the opposite of what we said we were
not being sincere at all and uh i submit
you know i submit the six videos with a
smile on my face
and we get this very stern email back
basically saying
what is this what what have you done
um
do it again they literally just said do
it again
so do it again yeah we went back and we
watched the pitch video and and you know
i i got to take the blame 100 percent we
did not deliver what we said yeah that's
so that's kind of an important piece um
versus a sincere heart to heart when a
man is talking about shaving his groin
sincerely it's just uncomfortable
nobody wants that yeah you know well
they should have reflected that and said
hey yeah that's going to be an
uncomfortable advertisement for people
yeah we you know we went the extra mile
and we recast the whole thing i rewrote
the whole thing we re-shot it we cut it
everything from the ground up and they
still gave us last place they're like
just to insult you know funny it was
horrific so
you know it's like a bad dream you know
like sometimes you know you have those
bad dreams of like being in a situation
and not realizing how you got there you
know
but like sometimes you make a video and
you watch it you're like
what
did i i made that like what happened
like where was i this whole time
especially in retrospect like looking
back on it for like a couple of months
later or something like it just gets
like it gets to the point where like who
made this you're so close to it in the
moment yeah you lose all track of it
yeah yeah it's like this is gonna make
sense
this don't work this will work like i
get this anyway it'll work it'll it'll
be fine
it'll be fine
yeah you just get television on projects
sometimes you know it does account you
gotta have to step back and be like uh
as an audience member someone that's not
close to this project like will they
understand it
well and it's through those mistakes
that you get in touch with like what's
important to them
trying to see things from you know their
side and that would be a thing that
you'd have to learn kind of over time
which is
hey i completely changed the tone of
this creative
is this something we should make them
aware of
or is this a
smaller creative choice that sort of
happens on the day yeah it was a series
of those
it was just a bunch of those like 3 000
small decisions that led us down this
path
and uh we just sent the final as the
first pass there you go we're all done
thank you
yeah this is what you want you'll like
it you're gonna like the way you look
see how we used that we used bush as a
metaphor do you like that it's pretty
clever
nope oh god pube jokes yeah yeah it's
that way it's that final 10 too that you
spend the most time on in the finishing
process once you know things are sort of
set in and
it's it's not always clear when you
should deliver something um for example
on this on this
uh punch for punch series this netflix
series um
i was gonna deliver it earlier because i
wanted to
get
get ahead of it you know and be like
okay can let's give it to them so they
can see how like the structure is is
being established
and nico uh to his credit said hey uh
let's let's give him like a
very polished look
yeah this and and obviously like if we
need to change it from there you know
that is what it is but
let's give him a very polished idea of
what the vision is uh and obviously not
take it that final five to ten percent
but
i'm glad we did it that way it seems to
work out yeah matt were you were you
confident submitting this were you
pretty
certain that they'd like it i liked it a
lot i the with people that we showed it
to people were liking it so you know but
again it's still this like
still kind of up in the air like you you
still don't really know i don't know
these people personally either so you
know i don't know what they're going to
be looking for but you know we we talked
about it in pre-production we had a
solid plan and we defined that plan to
them so
you know it was just a matter of like
did we do our due diligence and
delivered something that they were
expecting and uh that seemed like they
were
and for people who maybe are in this
situation themselves like the best thing
you can do is just
stay creatively honest to yourself
because you know you'll go through
the process of making it and
things will change or you need to add
something or take something out and
if you're if you're sort of creating
something completely to somebody else's
vision that's something you're not
interested in at all
then a lot of times
things get lost because
if you don't find it interesting like
matt was saying like when when you
delivered it you felt that it was good
yeah and that's that has a lot of value
kind of throughout the process like if
it's a concept and you're just not
stoked on it
you know
if you're trying to get work under your
belt that's one thing and that's kind of
the proving ground in the learning area
but
um
you know
after after a time you want to say i i
don't really want to do that style so
i'm not going to do that video yeah
yeah and it's also like an experience
thing i feel like your quality control
gets better over the course of you know
many years of working with clients and
delivering things so you kind of know
like you know what they
what they would want just based on how
you've been talking and how things have
been working in pre-pro
all right so hit us with your horror
story matt what you got
gorski you have anything first
he's like he's about to go no this
project i just delivered that's my
horror story i'm i've been pretty public
i feel like yeah about
my horrors well i haven't heard it i've
no shame in talking about it i haven't
heard of anyone i mean jeez
dude
i mean truly of my lifetime the biggest
horror story was the whole lifeline
shoot with youtube people oh yeah and
like i mean i've talked about it a bit
in the past but like it's compared to
everything else it is like the ultimate
horror story
when it comes to just like house of
horrors
the the just the cluster of of like the
process and and like
yeah i mean we shoot this thing and
they're editing the script and they're
casting people for us we're not meeting
these people and then
people show up to set we're like oh crap
you're the actor for the scene and like
we're like little youtube guys so for us
like maybe yeah that's totally normal in
the tv industry but we're really clear
up front we wanted to audition people
and figure out the stuff blah blah blah
but then uh the
i mean i don't i guess they're like yeah
sure exporting through this but like the
big thing was too it's like we would
edit the stuff we hired casey to do the
music for it it was
going pretty smooth
and then it was just it turned into this
whole like all right we're putting down
the hammer we're hiring new editors
we're firing casey we're taking control
of this stuff no you know we're redoing
half the stuff here and that's that's
basically where
nico and myself are like whatever yeah
and then we were just like
do we have to be here everyone's like no
it's like cool oh that's brutal wow so
they just took the reigns entirely yeah
yeah yeah your baby from your it wasn't
even that much of our baby well
no i mean well actually let me just this
is this is the true cluster which is
there were six scripts for six episodes
that were approved i read them i thought
they were cool we signed the contract to
be directors on the project and then
they scrapped the scripts and wrote them
from scratch and we're like god like
what like so wait hold on what is this
project gonna be and so then it was like
the whole thing got flipped and turned
they i think they added episodes they
made it longer they changed the whole
tone of it it was like basically
completely different show from what we'd
like signed a contract and agreed to do
well and the contract still it wasn't
null
like no because that was that wasn't
that we didn't know yeah because it it
basically allows it allowed for all that
oh wow and i mean i was eager to do it
still because i was like man i want the
experience yeah uh it was a good
experience from a learning perspective
but it was just it was just like
constantly it was rug pull after rug
pull yeah and well did they they cast on
your behalf or they recast
without you knowing about it oh it's
just like zero there's
just it's just it happens and then we
find out who's
on the day they're showing up to set
three times
yeah
that's awful yeah it's just it's just
just it was just nasty because like i
mean once again in a normal tv show
universe that's totally totally normal
but this was supposed to be like youtube
creator collaboration you know like
we're sitting here
it was like everything from us having to
call the unions to be like hey can we
like shoot part of this we have our own
cameras
and they're like no you can't touch the
cameras you're directors oh and like
what in your channel like we can't have
like some exception because this is a
youtube show and they're like no
it's like
so i mean it's just this mountain of
like little janky like wacky things all
the way to the fact that like the entire
crew basically was just
what's the word uh you know they were
very bitter about being there because it
was a youtube show youtube was hiring
them and it's like okay well is this a
youtube show or not because it's not
freaking operating one like one
and so
that's that's the production that burned
me from like the whole
system
system yeah yeah
it was just like every
every single time
i've worked with a crew
that another producer has hired it's
like i feel like everyone just hates me
like from the day i get to set up
just like no matter what happens it's
just like hi it's like cool you're
stupid
and you're full [ __ ] and we're not
gonna listen to you and everything
you're gonna at request
we will do begrudgingly there's no
there's no like
i don't know that feels like a culture
thing though honestly like all all the
different sets i've been on
there's this pervasive sense of
like
like upset and frustration and anger
like built into so many of these sets
and i'm just thinking like everyone
chose to be here right like we all
took these jobs it's just weird there's
like a built-in grumpiness
it's it doesn't need to be that way yeah
it's like this jaded anger it's and it
it gets to you it really does like even
if you go in there with optimism and
positivity you know in whatever
department you're in like being in an
atmosphere like that it eats at you over
time i know and like
yeah it's like i guess some people can
get through that if they have the right
personality to like
you know come back even more aggressive
you know or something like that the
michael bay approach
it's like you're fired
as of now you know it's like surprise
you're fired like that attitude it's
like i mean i'm not i try and be a
little more polite than that so
it's it doesn't really jive with me oh
man
yeah it was tough it came at a tough
time too that project uh it came at a
time when uh there was still this pretty
big transition happening from
traditional to what was still referred
to as new media
for the longest time like people forget
that term but that that was the term it
was like there's tv and there's movies
and then there's new media
and it was like what's new media it's
everything that's not tv and movies it's
like um
okay
and that no one knew quite like how to
approach it because there was only so
many people in it and
you know when these people would come
over from more traditional areas and
things being run and done a certain way
it's just very hard to break that mold
yeah for sure and that's funny when it's
the line so blurred now you know
yeah now yeah and now it's things are
things are definitely
getting better in terms of like where
overall the industry is settling um
but uh it's still not quite there you
know there's still a lot of stigmatisms
and things like that out there but i
think by and large
there's been a big shift in terms of the
stigmatisms towards
non-tv and film productions is kind of
going by the wayside because people see
how valuable it is and and there's more
money in it now too
there's more money being spent in
digital advertising than in traditional
advertising now and it crossed that
threshold
i think three years ago
were you a producer on this job jake on
lifeline no i um i think i'm credited as
like an associate producer or something
but uh i had very little involvement oh
i was doing all the co i was doing all
the corridor like youtube stuff while
sam oh
you're just digging up from the trenches
don't want to talk about one because it
kind of comes off pretty bad of all
parties
um
oh man now you have to say it
no i don't want to say that okay all
right well i've gotta hope maybe your
story aligns with mine sam because i was
gonna talk about the division
oh interesting
and you know that's
that was the infinity
project oh dude the vision was it went
the infinity project so it's a similar
setup because uh we were approached
about it
and uh
when they said hey we want you guys to
do uh three youtube videos three youtube
videos three youtube short films
sort of just like exposing uh aspects of
the game universe it'll be really fun
it'll be really cool you get to use your
own sets and cruise
you know here's some money have at it
and we were like that sounds awesome
let's do that
um and then they're like okay
we're gonna add one more video and we're
like um
okay
and we were i think we were a little too
young and and dumb at the time to like
you know go well okay you know what is
that and are you going to pay more and
no it was like all under the same terms
so we agreed to original terms which is
for like three videos
and then
all the things that got added on to that
were still under the same terms of pay
and everything else
and that was our fault for not like
stopping but but the thing was is by the
time we got far enough along where we
realized what was happening we had
already like spent money on it we had
already spent time on it and we were
already like into it you know
um and so there was a little bit of that
uh but it started off as three videos
then they added four then we went out
and shot them and
you know we were pulling favors like
left and right oh it was crazy yeah
because the expectation was like hey
make some cool youtube videos and then
this basically the balloon just grew and
grew and grew to the point where like
the expectations were like all right you
guys
we're almost making a feature film at
this point
yeah now we want 35 minutes and we're
delivering it to amazon
whoa
yeah and i'm and so we're yeah oh my god
and and we had we had uh we shot it like
a youtube video you know and and we used
the money to get like a cool street in
downtown st paul
we had like military vehicles we had
some sets we had some cool stuff um
and but we were still doing it very
scrappy like on on youtube you know
youtube money
um and then they were like uh okay um
you know so we had to make we had to cut
corners we had to like shoot one of the
videos
in the airbnb that we were staying in
and i had to like because we didn't have
money for a location and and so then i
had to ask the landlady if we could
shoot in there and thankfully she was
super nice um she was awesome uh you
know our buddy max like let us film in
his uh uh design she has like this high
end like shoe and
and apparel company he let us film in
the shop and like do a ransacked looted
scene in his shop without any money in
exchange just for us to like
you know do a bts and in the bts like
show off the shop interview him and then
like
you know show what he's about and they
completely cut the bts from the whole
thing so like all the favors that we had
pulled you know in terms of like
exposure
had no value
um and then they and then we got it all
done and we delivered it and they're
like great this is so good and it's it's
it's awesome we want you to add
uh a bunch more scenes to tie the whole
world together as one
which was not what we agreed to
these are four
it was it was three and then it became
the begrudging four
short films that were all they were very
specifically
they are different stories in different
places about different people
completely unrelated it's time together
and then yeah and then they're like time
together and so we do all that and we
come back to los angeles
we put our cameras down we pack
everything up okay close the shop we
edit them and we then they're like cool
cool cool videos now
you need to turn them all into one piece
no
and yeah and it's like what like
so we're sitting there like
brainstorming like how do we
how do we it's like
mind you we're like we're
we're like we're like six figures deep
in spend at this point
this was like this was like when we that
was
we were running on very small budgets
yeah so
yeah i think the first brainstorming
session where that was brought up we all
were like we don't know what
i don't know if we're gonna do
i i don't know what to do do you know to
do no and so we're like okay that's the
end of the meeting like wow
i mean could you could you not just say
no to that request
what was that yeah what did they have
we could have but there was different
there was different things that happened
along the way that we
because we had worked with the people
who brought us the project before in the
past and we'd always had good success
with them they were some of the first
people that brought us brand
integrations to be honest and uh and
like dedicated videos
and we had always had good luck with
them in the past and we just
like
got into a situation where things kept
changing but our terms didn't change and
then we had spent so much that we were
like well we we need to finish it so
that we can get paid because even if
they just pay us for the work done that
just brings us back to zero you know
it's like and now we've we've put and
then at that point we had put like six
months into the thing
already um and so it was just it was a
it was a lot of naivety it was learning
it was trusting people in ways when it
comes to like agreeing to certain
aspects of a project that you shouldn't
just you know do on handshake deals or
or verbal agreements things like that
that we learned um it was different
things along the way where we had to you
know we had to stop and say look i know
that's what you want but this is what we
can do we hadn't learned that yet we
hadn't learned like
this is what you want this is what i'm
capable of so so
do you want this or do you want that
because i can't give you that right now
unless this this and this happens we
didn't we didn't have that sort of
you know education and this project
honestly educated us in that in a lot of
different ways
um but at the end of it we we ended up
spending a year on it
and uh the epitome of the final delivery
so now this had gone all the way up to
ubisoft's like ceo who had seen the
project and was like yeah this is so
cool and like we want to put it out on
amazon so then they without our
permission like went out and brokered
this separate deal with amazon
the guy who was our direct
representative with ubisoft was like
treating us completely like commercial
clients
that that was another thing he had come
from the commercial world not from the
youtube and digital ad world he'd come
from like the traditional commercial
world and so his rules and expectations
were just completely different
you know there was like no adherence or
like um
there was nothing given to the fact that
we were going to be presenting this on
our platforms you know
um and and so that was also very
different but the epitome of it all was
we went to deliver it to net uh to sorry
not netflix to amazon they'd send us a
spec sheet for delivery
and it's like okay cool here's your spec
sheet for delivery what's the format oh
it's ultra wide okay we have two three
five two three seven and two three nine
and you can deliver in these formats and
obviously two three seven that's an
analog format that's for film delivery
when you actually shoot something on
film there's a there's a delivery aspect
ratio called two three seven to one and
that's how wide the picture is and the
digital conversion to that is 21.9 it's
a very standard digital format
and so i was like okay cool we're that's
fine yeah great two three seven yeah we
got twenty one nine we're good and they
were like no two three seven and i was
like yeah twenty one nine and they're
like no like
two three seven i was like
but it's pixels
it doesn't it doesn't it the math
actually doesn't multiply to that ratio
and they're like well you need to make
it multiply to that ratio and i was like
oh change math
jake yeah and i was like what do you
mean and they're like yeah it's
they're not going to accept delivery if
you don't deliver it in 237 and i was
like no they will it's fine they're like
no and then they then they and then they
were so like
just down into the trench of like oh oh
and there's what to do and also when it
came for the amazon delivery thing too
by the way the fun the like the true
the joy the true joy came so we do all
this stuff we put it all together we
sent it to amazon obviously he's having
this resolution debacle but the true
cream of the crop the icing is um as he
said we shot outside frequently
there was like lots of scenes in streets
we had cars oh we had a scene we had a
scene
we had a scene where we were like
everyone please bring your car today we
want to make the car just like the
street just like completely full of cars
in fact no we had like two or three of
those scenes but the point is
we had this one big scene
and so there's like i don't know there's
like 15 cars on the street or something
like that
and they're like okay so this huge scene
you do in the street with the cars so
since we're amazon uh by the way
we need you to uh paint out all the
license plates
of all these cars in the street to go on
amazon and we're sitting there going
what like
like how
how
and we're like oh this is every shot
every this is every shot oh
logo this is like every single shot and
every single logo and all it's just like
oh my god if you can contextualize how
much
time are we talking about to do this it
was a 15 minute it was it's like a 12 or
15 minute finished piece and about seven
of that is this action scene in the
street with these cars so it's just
seven minutes of pure license plate it's
so bad yeah
we had asked them we had asked them
going into that we were like hey look uh
we know that amazon delivery is like at
that point it was a concept that they
had like bounced off of us it was not
official we were like look like is that
gonna be a problem because we can greek
all these logos right now and it'll save
us
you know
a ton yeah and we're like
he's completely unqualified obviously
right totally unqualified because these
decisions came much later on from people
much higher up yeah and the people
talking we're talking to or you know in
marketing departments and you know
writing about yeah like
releasing of platforms and filmmaking
and like
no concepts the procedure you know and
can i blame them
a little bit
but ultimately
it's it's it really just keeps circling
back to the naivety thing of of like
we make this and then then we make it
again and then we make it again and then
we make it again and the whole time
through it's not like hey can we have
any help with this and they're like no
yeah like okay so in the in that
situation again when you ask the
question about the license plates how
would you handle that differently now
i would say i wouldn't
there's two answers to that question
answer one is i would have had the
conversation earlier about where this is
gonna be released and make sure that's
much more firmly planted
and so that if it comes up again it
would be like
hey can you release it on amazon and
paint out the license plate so be no
yeah right we're not doing that yes
right you know that that's that's the
true the true answer if the and then if
there and if there had been talks
already about releasing it on a platform
before that point in time yeah i would
have just like
taped them up or something yeah and
those are the most heartbreaking vfx too
because it takes so long and the result
is the exact same shot the exact same
shots
had to do a shot rena to do a shot where
we we we had true special effects on set
we we popped a taxi windshield and all
this glass comes raining down in front
of the logo no on the door
and ren had to
get rid of all that actual practical
glass which looked so cool
and then put a fake logo over the other
one and then replace all the glass
yeah
and so that's brutal yeah and so i would
have i would have done the same thing as
sam said like you you make the decision
early on and if and if somehow the
fundamentals you got to know what the
fundamentals are at the fundamentals are
like what are we delivering and where is
it going
and and and those what are we delivering
comes down to like okay it's three
episodes it's this tone this is the
style these are what the stories are and
this is where it's going if any of that
changes you now need to change terms
completely
um and we didn't do that and then the
other thing was once we got down later
when you're on set and you're in that
decision it's like well you have two
options you either greek everything on
set right then and there or you leave it
as is and then when it gets to post and
they say okay we're going to send it to
this other place that we didn't agree to
at the time you shot it you go okay well
either no
or we're gonna need money to do that and
those are your only options it's not
okay we'll do it
it's fun yeah it's funny you say that
because as a vfx supervisor those were
my two go-to answers as well when
producers would approach me about
changes to the creative it was always
either
no
because normally i would do the back-end
vfx work as well or my favorite was
always saying yes but it will cost more
and more often than not that was enough
of a deterrent
to the creative change which kind of
showed how important it was to them in
the first place which is always
interesting so
so then we get to this delivery
which i haven't finished the story quite
yet
and they so what i had to do on the day
of final delivery i had to take the
final export which i i believe nick did
the final export
i took that final file i brought it back
into premiere
and i put black bars
on the top and bottom
i remember this still to this day it was
three pixels on the top and it was four
pixels on the bottom
well
and then i redelivered it
gosh
it was
those pixels
yep thank god for those pixels yeah
there's no way it would have ever played
anywhere
it would have been incompatible with all
the screens everywhere
in fact now it's probably less
compatible
yeah because yeah
they don't make two three seven monitors
but two three seven by the way is like a
figment of your imagination
right there's no
screens screens are 21.9 like that like
that aspect ratio is real
unless you're literally unless you're
literally watching it projected onto a
screen in which case you can actually
truly watch 237.
oh
yeah
are you doing the math
but if you're actually watching it on a
digital display it cannot display in
that
because it it goes to quarter and a half
it goes to fractioned pixels
i was wrong sorry oh
21 9
it's the other way around i just
realized i just had to stop myself i was
like wait a second i already did the
math earlier
21 9
is unfortunately not real
i don't know who says 21 nine but two
three seven is real two seven is real
sorry two three seven so when you see a
monitor advertises twenty one nine it
might not be mm-hmm just saying uh fake
news
237 is real wait well doesn't it
actually have to
okay i don't know i i don't know about
this
237 are different so i'm just going to
take that pain point and validate it
really quickly
[Laughter]
the use of the word pain point oh my god
a pain points like pain
we talk about pain points here let me
just turned into my lexicon as a
post-traumatic stress trigger every once
in a while what if like we get like a
little brief or something on someone who
wants to do a sponsorship on a video or
we're working with a company
occasionally they'll send a list of pain
points pain points pain points and
usually the pain points are like
hilarious things like
uh you know let's say let's i'm just
gonna make up a fictional situation a
laptop company recently had a laptop
explode and it burned some child's
fingers so they would list a pain point
as showing images of fire
uh showing anyone under the age of 12
using our devices
showing burnt fingers showing uh
yes
fingers with a a a gray value that is
less than 30 percent
yes
the corporate pain points of like so so
we did something very bad and uh we
would like to avoid these
this is how we like to avoid ever
talking about it reminding anyone that
this ever happened we're sorry
yes right we're sorry
the same point sorry it's like jeez this
is how in america works i wonder what's
wrong with society
you walk up the stairs you mentioned
like three pain points
they literally like their back their
back breaks and they crumple yeah and
all of their bones dissolve if you
mention too many pain points oh we have
a friend
a real crumpler yeah man
so so yeah so that's uh that's my horror
story and after that
we learned our lesson we said okay all
right we're we'll do this type of work
again if
certain parameters apply
and i think that's to to this day that's
why the punch for punch first delivery
went well because when they came to us i
was like look
we don't really do
we don't really do this type of work
anymore you know like if you want us to
do this work first of all it's it's
gonna be it's gonna take a long time
it's not gonna be cheap and we're gonna
do it our way if you're not comfortable
with those things then i appreciate your
time but we're not the people for you
and that's like the first thing that i
told them and they were like no that's
that's why we want you guys is because
you have this style and tone that we
think would be perfect for this idea and
and it's like okay well then great then
the next step is we'll come up with the
ideas
and send them to you for approval yeah
yeah and that's like super important too
because like especially
like in this type of relationship where
you're doing it remotely and it's just
like emails or messages and stuff like
that like the creativity top to bottom
is happening in literally like
basically a different world you know
like everything is happening and then
to deliver like creative notes on that
kind of stuff where it's just like make
a film and then show it to me a year
from now and i'll tell you what that
changed you know it's like it's like
what what is that like i'll know it when
i see it it's like we're not gonna do a
payroll you know
we're not on a payroll here it's like we
just
yeah sorry
it's like it'll be different if like we
were like literally working in the
netflix studio for a year oh sure yeah
things could move around but like
yeah
yeah any any contracts work like that it
really just there's no such thing as
over communication that's that's one
thing that took me a little too long to
learn but once you learn it it's like no
you cannot over communicate
every question every every clarification
like get it down
preferably for me get it down on paper
on email get it down where you can
allude to it later in the future just
protect yourself by over communicating
as much as possible yeah yeah
no totally although and
yeah i almost want oh it's maybe a
little too recent
no but you're cause you're talking about
the black rifled coffee guys and so like
i love working with those they're super
fun to shoot with i love filming all the
stuff with them it's always a hoot yeah
but it was really funny last year with
the commercial because we you know
we made this commercial with them at
bass pro shops we were all aimed to do
it we had a script we made storyboards
for the entire thing yeah you know yeah
every we we basically was like yeah
here's the whole thing it's probably
gonna be about like three or four
minutes long and here's the deal
and uh we the only mistake we made was
we sent a rough cut
yep there you go
with working with those guys like their
filmmaking approach is generally like
you know they
they
they're adding more bells and whistles
on their stuff right now and doing more
you know cinema vfx blah blah but you
know at that point in time it was still
very much like a you know you can do
half the effects in premiere kind of
video yeah and so when we sent him the
rough cut we were like oh yeah like yeah
of course like we know oh yeah we'll put
some final sound of music and put a ton
of vfx yeah but we just wanted to like
get a feeling of this but we sent it and
like you know
the response from evan was like what the
[ __ ] is this
i mean obviously we went through a ton
of revisions after that and i was like
you know
you know i want to make them happy you
want to i want to make this go well
because it's fun working with them
um yeah it was it was it was very much a
shocker yeah after after like
storyboarding the thing and like having
it all like
very well planned out
yeah and uh it's just like those vfo the
vfx goggles weren't on
yeah well evan's evan's not a he's not a
film guy he's not a video guy like he
he's been in a ton of videos but he's
he's a coffee guy that's what he knows
he doesn't know
he you can't send them a draft and go
like yeah and there'll be a bunch of
cool visual effects and sound design and
this will be smoothed out and that'll
look better and we'll put some color on
that like no he just looks at it and
goes what the [ __ ] is this yeah i mean
so i immediately took the edit and i was
like all right i'm doing sound design
right now i'm just like doing as much as
i possibly can to like
just just
bring it to that 90 quality mark as fast
as possible and then
then we
went through a bunch of revisions on it
but yeah yeah there was one other
mistake we made with that video which is
in order to film in that bass pro shop
we had to agree to
you know this was still like uh height
of the pandemic um and so uh bass pro
shop obviously was like hey you know
um
we don't want to show crowds and the
whole pitch originally was like
look this is a black friday sale and
there's a crowd out front yeah
yeah and the crowd turns into a mob and
it turns into a massive fight scene for
the coffee
yeah that was that was yeah it was
supposed to be the
you know the shot of like all the people
on black friday like going underneath
the gate that's only like a foot open
that was like the original idea and then
it would have eventually whittled down
to like no it can't be that no it maybe
shouldn't be that and then so we end up
kind of filming the same concept but
with no people and so it's like yeah
this is just a little weird now we
didn't quite have the budget to do to
like do a recreated department store you
know because the whole idea was like we
are going to destroy
the department store
like it's it's and and but then it was
like oh well we can't
we'd have to recreate the whole store
you know like in order to do that and so
there was a couple creative mistakes
there that we should have identified
before going into it but
it's like it's like everything's changed
but we're still making the same script
yeah different everything else
and
you know whatever
yeah
so
yep no and it's it's never a perfect
process that's for sure no no yeah i
mean the big lesson is like i feel like
too not to
not to be like an [ __ ] about stuff
and being so stern at the forefront of a
project that it can never get done it's
all about like having that fluidity to
like get the ball rolling you know it's
like you want because that's the only
way you can get the ball rolling if it's
like everything has to be this way and i
won't do a project unless i have
everything like this and i get my
muffins at 7am and like that is
important and you're gonna tie my shoes
for me every time i get the set you know
it's like you know
you don't want to enter in with that
attitude of like i'm so protected you
know like i think that's you want the
like the play loose you know like nature
so that way like the project can start
but it's about it's important to like
after now it's started to like
just try and like fall into like a
pattern of of like the s's and the nose
because
like that's that's that's what keeps it
from spiraling out of control but like
yeah if you were entering the project
with that like no i refuse to do this
it's like then good luck getting it yeah
you're not gonna get very much work that
way
yeah and you know it was like it was it
was a rough time to be filming stuff
when we shot that uh coffee bit and you
know so there was a lot of factors that
were new to people and
the store manager was super cool
like you know yeah it's like
here we are
mid-2020
whatever we're on film so who goes to
[ __ ]
that's the big thing is like covet times
that like really changed the script a
lot so that was like a huge impact kind
of did but it like it really didn't
affect our shoot at all because like i
knew other people were doing shoots at
the time and it was like okay so we need
to have like three coven monitors that
monitor people going in and out and
we're going to be doing coveted tests uh
every single day for every like there's
like a whole nother level of operation
that like we kind of skipped because we
were
just doing you know
just yeah we were able to get by
a lot of different yeah aspects that we
probably wouldn't have been able to do
otherwise
our production manager she was uh
she was she was great she was super
detailed but she was like very worried
about that she was very worried about
that i mean
i had to talk her off the ledge a few
times i was like it's okay it's gonna be
fine
um no and the store was super cool i
like that guy that manages that store
basically had the right to say yes or no
to that whole shoot and he was so
generous and just awesome the whole time
yeah yeah
it was chill it was chill yeah
oh boy well uh i don't think there's
anywhere else to hide matt
i think i think you're up all right
this is probably gonna end our podcast
too which is very send it out
y'all it seems like y'all story is like
you learned something from your stories
and like you know there was a personal
growth um i had none of those things in
this story
okay so
i first of all i was in my like early
20s i was like 22 23 i was just getting
the ball rolling in florida doing making
films in florida
um
and i i was hired on to do this this
project that was like it was really good
money and it was like gonna be over the
course of like a year doing a bunch of
uh these these like tv ads like local tv
ads for uh this anti-bullying campaign
right
and this is amazing
it was a good cause it was a good you
don't want bullies you had that
government contract didn't you yeah so
so no bullies were allowed so during the
process of making this like no bullies
no no no no bullies here well there was
um
[Laughter]
the lady that hired me um she was like
in her 50s or so right um it's kind of
aw there's something like a little bit
off about her but i don't know when i
when i agreed to it i really needed the
money at that time so it was really like
you know hell yeah i'll sign on for this
you know oh the whole year of this
really good money and this good contract
that we have um so we get into the first
uh the first campaign right the first
like 30 second spot that's gonna go on
and i finish it uh and she loves it
right um she's the head of this
anti-bullying campaign right um and she
we we go into final delivery on it and
she actually comes over to my place to
kind of do a little review session
finalize it cool it's good to go i
deliver it to her she makes you know she
pays me on the spot too which is oh
great wow money in my hand that's
awesome um
and i cash
yeah cold
it's coincidence
[Laughter]
i'm trying to i'm trying to look for the
warning signs she has a she has a
passion
see if you can spot the warning signs
listener all right so
so i i show her to my door right uh and
you know she's she's about to walk away
and then she turns around oh no makes
direct eye contact with me
and then reaches down and grabs both of
my testicles
and makes direct eye contact with me
while she does it and it felt like an
eternity those couple of seconds where
she just
complete 180s from professionalism to
grabbing both of my testicles i i i was
absolutely frozen
in place
i
couldn't break eye contact either by the
way i was just like i was staring into
her eyes she was staring back at mine
and she finally releases her clench from
my testicles
and she simply says you got a lot of
junk in the trunk
no matt and then she walks away
out of all the for the anti-bullying
campaign which doesn't make sense by the
way junk in the trunk doesn't make any
sense she's not where the truck is
[Laughter]
you're ahead of your time
she was yeah so so maybe to her that
wasn't bullying because she was giving
you a compliment
no it's just like this is fine that's
right it's not bullying it's just sexual
harassment
because i believe there's more spots you
had to do
yes there was
i
i took a step back for a second after
that moment and was like
i can't work with her
right i'm not gonna do this so you
didn't say anything she she walked away
no no she so yeah so she says that and
then she just walks away and i'm just
frozen in place so i can't really like i
can't do any i'm not doing anything i'm
just like um but i didn't have to work
with her directly on like the actual
videos so i i was just like i really
needed the money
and it was like such a good opportunity
for the man of the night and i was just
like i gotta do i gotta at least do i
gotta see if maybe we just don't like go
show up or do anything like i don't see
her again and just do the things so i
did another one
and
she
she actually shows up on set while we're
filming
and
and it's already like super weird
already and stuff and so like we wrapped
that day out and she's like oh this is
so awesome that you're doing this it's
just like it's just me and her talking
and it's so weird like in the parking
lot
and then
the fingers come out
she she brings her hand out of her
pocket her fingers start trembling
and once again she reaches down and
tries to grab him
she does it again but i swear to god
she's acting super normally up until
this point like like and i thought i was
like maybe this was a fever dream before
maybe it just maybe we'll just forget
this and let bygones be bygones here
maybe she just wants a little piece of
me and she goes down and grabs again i
back away i'm like don't don't ever do
that again and i don't want to work with
you again
i'm sorry this is not gonna happen um we
we need to break all this like the
contract we gotta we gotta figure out
how to end this right now i can't like
continue with this what did she what did
she say and she was like taken aback
like it was weird that i said something
she was in shock like oh wow i'm sorry
it's in the contract man that's in the
coffee shop it's in the contract
you didn't you clearly didn't read the
card you had to go through that bro
that's crazy yeah it is crazy i i will
never forget that it's really like you
won't probably
it's not something that you forget
oh boy that is wild yeah well yeah
luckily at that point i had enough of a
brain to be like that's get enough junk
in the trunk to say i had enough joking
to walk away upstairs
that's what really matters
upstairs tesla trunk yeah
oh my gosh matt that is so much more
extreme than i expected yeah that is far
more extreme than i i thought it was
just gonna yeah i was like
that was weird here i'm here talking
about pixels
i'm trying to think through it at all
you must have just drove home in silence
just thinking through that like uh
what
yeah definitely yeah but you had how
many more did you do how many more oh no
i did none more but but
oh there was like there was like 10. and
you just you just yeah at that point i
was just like you know we got it did you
did you tell anybody why you were
leaving the job or was it just well i
told myself yeah the people i worked
with definitely yeah yeah yeah i gotta
go i was like look this this lady don't
work with her please like
i just thought at the end of the
conversation she took her hand out of
her pocket like okay now it's that well
that was
like
warms it up
[Laughter]
that is surreal
ugh
yeah it's real guys that's so you got to
watch out for those folks too
like i said you didn't learn a thing
from that well at least you managed to
dodge it the second time i did well yeah
she grabbed a little she grabbed like
the tail she got like the tip
fingernail like kind of a little yeah
that is
this is like
almost like you can't do anything get
it sounded like the story was gonna be
worse i mean that's a high closer we
gotta we're done here boys
yeah jesus christ
no one can follow that no no
no
yeah man stay on your toes that's the
yeah oh i have been for the rest of my
life
i'm not talking about being nimble i'm
just saying if you need to go tiptoe
through
it's just like a class three felony it's
okay yeah seriously like that's so
that's like creepy that's right so yeah
man that is but you know at least we
have the comfort of being able to laugh
it off yeah yeah
speaking for you well yeah well i'm
clearly laughing about it next time on
the corridor cast jordan's going to
explain how he got stuck in canada
everybody kept their hands in their
pockets on that trip though so i'm well
i'm gonna you were there with your
girlfriend so i don't know
stranded in the northern territories
gracious to the north
yeah
matt i'm sorry man wow
okay buddy that's all right
keep your head on a swivel out there
people i'm gonna play
i would love some uh music for my sweet
boy uh whatever his name is yeah give
him get whatever he wants to burn my
burns
it's your day today you get whatever you
want
in solidarity i'm gonna just put my
hands in
keep those hands in those pockets
put your hands in your
[Music]
they might throw a note at you or they
might do something else
they might throw a note at you or have
you work it out but watch out who
you work with
the old crab clap
little class b see you guys later thanks
for listening everybody oh man